I was in London a few weeks ago and at a
party and I was the guest of honor and
they brought out last year's Welsh
mushrooms and made a big tea for
everybody and the hostess said you know
it's it's just it's just almost like a
gesture I mean there's so many of us and
so few mushrooms but we'll each just get
a little bit well so I was first out of
the chute and you know I was I don't
know whether it all pooled on the top
and one page
what was going on but you know I just
sat down on the ground and this guy who
said it is some person of great
reputation you said he'd wanted to meet
me for years and years was sitting in
front of me
trying to get to know me and and finally
he just said he said you're flaming
aren't you and I said yes I can't carry
on this conversation I just have to hold
on to the grass well I don't know what
all this means I don't want to become
afraid of it and I blame myself I don't
think the thing has a negative edge
unless you've somehow come out of jiggle
with it and I don't know whether that
means you know it what does it mean if
it becomes harder and harder to take
these things does it mean you're getting
out of balance does it mean you're just
getting older where should the blame be
put and then what can you do about it
the only thing I found to do about it is
stop running and turn and face it but
each time I do have a chance to require
the very limit of my courage and I don't
know how long one's courage laughs maybe
it's not a bad thing I mean after all
people who climb mountains like Mount
Everest
they don't do it till their dying day at
some point they you know knock off and
the kind of consultant
that's where manufacture